today's very unique episode of this past
weekend is brought to you by gray block
pizza gray block pizza get that hitter
and you know we like to support our
listeners and their small businesses and
today's small business goes to stove
shelf now this is really interesting
some people you have a stove and the top
of your stove there's not any room on it
you're trying to lean you put a little
thing a lemon pepper and you lean it off
the stove onto the back of the wall or a
little thing a dill dill flavoring well
now this is stove shelf stove shelf is a
magnetic shelf that attaches to the top
of your stove so now that awkward space
is suddenly a shelf it comes in three
finishes stainless black or metal it's
compatible with most flat and curved
kitchen stoves it's available in 24 and
20 inch models for apartment stoves you
can purchase through Amazon eBay or
stove shelf dot-com and you can get 15%
off with promo code theö th EO at stove
shelf com
that's promo code Theo at stove shelf
dot-com why have that awkward space you
can't put nothing right there you're
trying to lean a picture of a little dog
or something right there or some extra
spice or a black pepper
you know booyah based seasoning do
something different stove shelf solve
your problem I want to let you guys know
in a few weeks
howie mandel is going to be in here and
he's gonna be just being himself and
being regular but before that you can
see him January 18th in his very first
Showtime comedy special in more than 20
years so you guys make sure to check
that out today here in studio we got a
special man and this is a man that I've
seen walking down the street that I've
seen on television as a child and as and
and now in person as an adult this is a
human male and he's from [ __ ] I don't
know he's from somewhere and we're about
to meet him and speak with him and I
want to introduce you to my friend
mister
[Music]
yeah I live in Westwood okay so not to
kind of drunk yes but I go sometimes too
I go to a meeting sometimes on the wet
over and uh because uh and I'll see you
in Palisades walking down the street
sometimes in the morning you might I
remember you go to the Palisades yeah oh
I know where you going The Woman's Club
finger though I yeah I mean it's for men
too
I know yeah I just the listeners to know
that it's not like I'm not considering a
sex change I know somebody else that
goes there - yeah half of the Palisades
gives and she talks about it all no my
listen to know about that so but um it
dude if I have a cleaning lady coming
over even a friend anyone I will I will
station things in my place because I
don't want them to like kind of see it a
certain way you know well yeah I mean I
have a I had a podcast I mean I had an
iPod songlist mm-hmm there was just the
show like younger people I was trying to
impress oh no it wasn't like the rock
and roll from the 70s you know who is
more like you know one direction and
yeah yeah yeah I listen to that you know
you could you could judge somebody lot
by their song list oh and a lot of fire
whatever oh especially if you're like
talking to somebody of a younger
generation yeah that's the worst it's
like the other day I was talking to this
younger girl and I was like so um you
know how school going and it was like
the oldest sounding thing you know it
just sounded like an old man question I
know it and you know it used to be the
bookshelves at home you just put books
in there to try to impress people
oh yeah coffee table books yeah you know
like you put out a book on engineering
or something really on maybe if you have
like a hot chick come over yeah okay
yeah engineering you can see that and
you hide all the Lego whose you look
like you are the scope the guns
nope although yeah yeah at least move it
a few feet away from the window
yes yeah I think that's the thing I'll
start thinking like okay I don't want
people to correlate because people see
two things in one space and then they
that an idea comes oh okay there's a
knife by the piano this guy is you know
maybe he's writing him you know a
seriously piano serial killer yeah yeah
yeah this guy you know he's just putting
a d-flat and everybody um D sharp yeah D
sharp
good call yeah but yeah I am you know I
uh I like to have a tidy house when
people come over some people don't
really seem to care
yeah I mean this stuff is everywhere and
you know there's dog peeing on the couch
and and you just think am I just like
overly tidy or is this guy like overly
sloppy yeah with some people's houses
have a very distinct scent did you ever
do that you ever go to somebody's house
you like yeah they don't realize how bad
their house smells I know it I know it
at least white a few candles man yeah
but they don't know it they don't know
it it's like body odor you know they
don't know it some people don't know my
son is a 11 and my wife is saying did
you put on your deodorant this morning I
think what I don't smell anything
dude look I'm an I'm 38 I'll smell an 11
year old you know just to kind of get a
buzz off their skin I feel like they
have so many as net oh that's weird
okay that's weird you're right actually
I just mean like in a sense that you
know you smell a baby and they just
smell like well the baby breath is
amazing when my son was you know eight
hours old up to you know a urine you
just put your mouth your nose in his
haste there you smell them breathing and
there's nothing wrong with it at all you
don't smell anything
no it's God's crystal meth for a woman
right if your system I feel like what
about Cologne you work alone you know
this is a good topic actually because I
feel like cologne is kind of becoming
extinct a little bit well I I have a
quite a collection in my drawer I
realized from over the years do you it's
just like I don't wear a lot of Cologne
yeah but somehow it's like guitars I've
kind of you know accumulative
accumulated in certain areas in my house
I don't collect it you just have a whole
stack of guitars you walk in the living
a Byerly nice smelling guitar yeah so
for the mandolin
they're mine but I you know I'll open up
the drawer like I remember I went out
one night and I open the tour I said
yeah you know maybe we'll try a little
this summer and I open it up put it on
and I go out and I'm with a bunch of
people so suddenly somebody goes oh my
god who's wearing a CK 21 maybe it's me
but I just took something out of the
drawer because that's like a children's
cologne now that's almost as bad as now
we're even because I was smelling the 11
year old and now you're we're okay we
had a guy in high school and he would
take the Cologne bottles an empty him
and he'd fill him with liquor so then
yeah and it was it was great because you
had liquor but you it was like I mean it
was like a just like estee lauder gin
you know like it was very you couldn't
help but get a little bit of the color
you know the perfume of the Cologne
don't some people drink cologne to then
have a real problem yeah yeah people
drink anything out of a kind of a
bathroom really kind of go up the
drawers it's like you start with like
the rubbing alcohol and you move your
way up think about a Ralph Lauren you
know he'll uh you know positive thing
about having a hangover in colonna's at
least your puke is smell good yeah drunk
but but you know it feel sometimes I'll
walk by somebody and I'll smell the
Cologne or the perfume and it'll hit me
I'll say oh my god that smells great I
don't want to ask the guy what he's
wearing yeah you know or the woman
sometimes but I should just say hey man
what do you wear me that smells really
good I'd like to have that as my
signature smell yeah you know yeah
that's a good stats actually a good way
to just go up somebody and say hey man I
would like to have that as my signature
smell the other great thing is like when
you perform somewhere and you know how
people say you know this guy needs no
introduction then you come out or some
comics don't even have an introduction
like you know Richard Pryor just walk
out on stage really you know people know
he's there yeah that's there who else is
gonna be I would like to have like a
signature cologne set right before I
come out they spray it in the area in
the room and people go that's Neil and
he's about to come out yeah it's just
like they hit the idea yeah it's just
popcorn and guitars or something you
just associate that smell with Kevin
Nealon a bad idea have you ever been in
one of those 3d movie theaters where
they have they put the smell and stuff
into the air and they shake the seat
yeah pretty cool
like that or the what it's not 3d it's I
think it's called like 4d or something
like that Wow
there's a in the zoo in San Francisco
they have a thing where you can watch
the Sharks on screen and you know and
they have water spraying out of the
seats and everything really yeah they
even have a little jaw that will bite a
little piece out of your leg it's so
cool so realistic it's blood everywhere
you know
EMTs show up EMTs show up they haul you
down to the hospital and it's an extra
service fee isn't it for the EMTs well
insurance usually covers it but there
are those instances where they don't but
but yeah I'm all about that I haven't
done the visual reality thing yet have
you
yeah hey Your Honor I have actually yeah
I went over to they have actually over
at Fox Fox Studios has a lab it's
opposed to like one of the best in the
country and it is man it was mesmerizing
I put on this you know you put on the
thing and then you put on the gloves too
yeah and they you know they turn it on
and they you know you know they tell you
that you know God doesn't exist and then
next thing you know they cut the screen
on and I was in a forest I was in I was
in a forest man I was in a really nice
for smell like a forest no so they
didn't have any of that they didn't have
you New York alone in the air actually
at one point I was like it's Kevin
Nealon in here Kevin Nealon about to
come out but they would have you would
hear something in the distance he would
see the leaves move and then you're like
and then a gnome would like run up a
little ladder that's when he was in a
tree and then he's running from a bridge
to a bridge and you can walk over to the
tree and you can like shake the little
bridge and he's on and he gets nervous
and then you could open the doors at
some of the trees it could run from one
to the other it sounds crazy see this
sounds like something that someone would
have said in a psych ward years ago you
know yeah yeah you could open the little
doors on the tree move closer to the
tree and look down in there and they'd
have two little gnomes in there like
drinking beers or getting trying on
clothes you could say something to them
and get their attention like when I shut
it off I felt so disappointed with our
natural existence hey that's what I
worry about I get too addicted to the
are thing that world
but what about gnomes man they're like
high-strung our thing in general because
they're always getting kidnapped your
hearts in the act of working gardens
they're basically slaves you know and
they wear those hats the pointy hats
they're always getting knocked off yeah
do you think they're confused with um
like the Seven Dwarves and things like
that
oh I'm sure a lot of them are
disgruntled because they didn't get the
job but they're not really little people
their homes
oh I got magic in them yeah little
people are just freelance middle you
know little people really middle ground
let's say you're gonna have a party okay
you put together your guest list
oh yeah let's say you're gonna have 50
people there percentage-wise how many uh
little people friends do you have that
you'd invite I have two little people
friends I probably would not invite them
invite that you know we're not invite
them yeah okay because they wouldn't fit
in no fit anywhere before yeah yeah
anywhere I guess I get I don't know I
just don't hang out with them that much
okay so they're not really friends
they're not really friends right how
many african-american friends
percentage-wise
in my life no for the party Oh for the
party I wouldn't I go to maybe to two
out of 50 yeah okay
how many I mean I waited Asian friends
oh I'm gonna probably eight or nine oh
eight or nine out of so almost one-fifth
yeah nice so I will double up on the
Asian you'll make up for the oh and I
want some laotians in there - how many H
how here's the question for you how many
little people
laotians mmm now that we need categories
I'll go for four okay
that sounds like quite a party right
look quite a party yeah I think so not
anybody with the morphine syndrome on
morphine no morphine you know that's
like the giant syndrome like Tony
Robbins Anthony Robbins I think has more
Fame syndrome does he really where your
hands get really long and on its big jaw
yeah yeah oh you can pick your nose from
like a distance yeah like yeah yeah like
hitting a three-pointer yeah well it
sounds it quite a party man
well some people have elongated
skeletons and stuff like that you know
yeah and that's morphine syndrome I
don't know if that would be more pain
syndrome but um but probably will
haven't looked that up as we're talking
but you know that there's less and less
people that are you know have syndromes
now yeah but I feel like everybody's
coming out with autism you know if
you've seen the new bachelor everybody
everybody on there is like well they're
all sitting on the spectrum well they're
saying hey you know I have a brother
with autism and it was like all of them
like you know they're trying to relate
to the man with the yeah they're looking
for that sympathy and it's like jeepers
like I don't haven't seen I love that
they should have a show with the
brothers on it and they have to prove
they have autism because I think
everybody's just claiming it now yeah
yeah that's a bad magnet yeah it is a
pape but you see puppies now it's my
brother's got autism yeah that's the new
babe magnet did you ever uh what was
kind of your ruse like you're honest
ruse to get women involved it with you
Kevin do you feel did you have never
really had a ruse I was really very shy
around women I know it wouldn't very
rarely ask a woman out coming up growing
up and or asked for their number because
I wouldn't be rejected but mine was just
to try to impress them mm-hmm like I get
in the stand-up comedy to try to impress
a girl I went to high school with Wow
you know who was a cheerleader and I was
just you know I was like five eight had
a baby fat you know no body hair that's
delectable almost a lot of Cologne some
IVs Laotians real you up but I I really
had no trick I had no no game in that
way you know I would maybe I would uh
what I like to do sometimes is not just
a girl but just to kind of like you know
I'll ask somebody their name I'll write
it on a piece of paper that'll make a
face out of that name which seems to
entertain people like so you'll take
Amanda in the letters and you'll make a
fait like oh yeah I'll write it in
cursive Amanda on the paper and then
I'll turn the paper different angles to
see what it looks like I can make a face
out of and then I'll make the face by
adding things and you know coloring it
in and stuff it's kind of cute yeah it's
it's a little gimmick yeah I used to do
this thing I remember I would be like oh
I got something for you that's what I
would say
I'd say I got something for you to a
girl and close your eyes that's what I
would say and then when they close your
eyes I would kiss them so I don't know
if that's a meaty I mean would you also
tie them up that's really clever what's
really clever it wasn't too bad it
wasn't too bad it was kind of fun um but
yeah it worked sometimes and then
sometimes if you know I run one time I
surprised you know it was too much of a
surprise friend of mine said that um if
he brought a girl back to his room in
hotel room um you know he would he would
say would you excuse you want to check
my messages and he sit on the side of
the bed mm-hmm any check his messages
and as I was checking him he'd single
the girl come over sit next to him and
he was listening to his message he made
me reach over and give her a kiss on the
neck you know just kind of like oh and
by the way that's that's just oh yeah
it's like oh there's something going on
that's important but also you were also
even more more important to um I know
that you're buddies with David Spade
right yeah I went over to his house the
other night to watch The Bachelor oh
yeah he has that little uh little video
thing he does right yeah so I go over
there I've never been to his house by
the way that's what kind of friends we
are
really yeah oh wow he talks about you
guys like you are very close well you
know we're close in the way that we both
run SNL and he rented my room from him
he rented my room from me when I went to
do SNL and he wasn't on it yet mm-hmm I
had a house in the Hollywood Hills so he
sublet it from me
Wow he got on the show did he throw any
parties like did you do something out of
like was there a moment you're like
David no no I didn't care I was that was
behind me yeah I don't think I ever went
back to that place yeah he's still
living there and so I went over there to
watch The Bachelor
he has me sit on the couch he sits in a
chair behind the couch mm-hmm there was
it just you you have the people just me
and him
Wow and it was dimly lit did he say I
have a surprise for you I did smoke
Kevin I've never watched The Bachelor by
the way I mean loved it
yeah how do you watch The Bachelor end
as well I don't Nick does a podcast on
what your podcast called Nick it's
called another Bachelor podcast there's
actually a lot of competition out there
so it's kind of meta spawned a lot of
work that show oh yeah I mean those
people getting on there and having a
chance at love you know yeah man but
none of that really lasts those those
reality shows aren't really reality no
no I mean you take Survivor for example
I've heard people talk about this like
if they're crossing a you know a log
over a river and they fall in they make
them do it again
yeah they love conflict you know get in
an argument with somebody
Oh scabies if you don't have scabies or
something about the second or third day
I heard they asked you to go home oh
yeah yeah yeah but people liked it's
like the National Geographic
it's like National Enquirer you just
want to go into that fantasy world and
want to maybe believe this is real
yeah do you think that um do you think
that there we could ever have real
reality TV cuz now there's so many laws
against what you can even you can't even
like play tricks on people in a lot of
places you almost have to go to England
or Africa really to do it well I you
know I love prank calls mm-hmm and
there's certain states you could do
prank calls in or you know they don't
have to know that you're being recorded
mmm
I think Vegas is one in New York people
when we did crank calls with Jimmy
Kimmel Crank Yankers Frank you were on
that yeah we would go with to Vegas for
the day and do crank calls from little
room there yeah that's all you guys I'll
just drive over and do it what we fly
yeah yeah I guess yeah at that point in
your career where are you from I'm from
Louisiana so easy Ana which city
I'm from Covington Louisiana it's like a
small town with a que no with the sea oh
I was thinking the one with a que no I
know that's very everybody in the South
thinks everything in the south that
starts with a cursed R to the K they say
Ches Ches right yeah clucks the clams do
these have a seafood restaurant not far
from us called Ku Klux Klan's
uh-huh yeah it's like for about eight
months it was open I thought it was it
was it was open for everybody but you
know this before now people would take a
pitch room like what's going on you know
what's going on
seafood [ __ ] you know that's
really happening
I am his baby plan it's like if you
can't make a joke about something you
know yeah you got a lot of products
around here you sponsored by these
people no no it's a friend of mine
started some beverage company and some
of this I grew up next to a jingle bell
outlets really oh yeah
I don't know that knows oh you get so
many bells man our whole town was just a
bringing brother around the holidays it
was just people start throwing bells at
each other I mean it was awesome I know
some people that lived in Switzerland
for a while in a chalet they rented it
for like a year
and when they first got there you know
there was no cows in the pasture it was
in the winter and then spring came all
of a sudden there's all cows the farmers
bring their cows up there and they're
the big bells around their necks and
constantly all day long ding dong dong
ding ding and they thought oh my god we
can't take this but eventually they got
used to it oh wow
and then when the cows left in the
winter it just seems so quiet up there
almost lonely oh wow
it's pretty cool yeah if we need you
could put different octaves on each neck
you know what sounds like they do have
some different plate songs yeah just get
a little something out of them yeah I'll
like you to walk that way and yeah yeah
but you know I was thinking about
products and stuff and your buddies got
this drink company here you think
everything's been done yeah whether it's
in films or in you know products or
whatever or podcast and then you hear
people or you see a movie anything wow
that one hasn't been done mm-hmm that's
I think that's what we're all trying to
come up with something that's really
unique so that hasn't been done or
people can't say oh that reminds me of
this or that yeah do you have something
that's new and what's new in your world
in the work world well I mean I got a
few things going I I do this hiking show
you know oh yes they did it didn't yes
they did it but they was very you know
particular about it took me about a year
to get him to come yeah cuz he's got to
have the right amount of food in his
body and there can't be not one iota of
any kind of incline on the trail it's
got to be perfectly flat
he's very plateau guy he's very we had
to flatline him oh wow I cut that's what
I call he was a flatline hiker and we
walked down a little you know decline to
get to the trail goes I guess we got to
walk back up this come
back right and he had to be out by a
certain time because of traffic you know
oh yeah and uh he was calculated yes but
he was great man I loved he was one of
my favorite hikes and but I'm you know I
got that hiking show on YouTube it's
called hiking with Kevin oh nice oh I
like that and we're taking that around
to try to sell it to uh you know
different platforms and then also I've
always wanted to direct a short film in
a regular-sized film and I wrote a
feature-length film but it's hard to get
financing for it is it but now how much
financing does a film like that need
like a yeah well I you know I wrote
everything very low budget so it came
out to fifty million Wow now it's like
3.8 it sounds like the Donald Trump I
came out to 3.8 and Wow really some lion
producer came out you know they the line
produces a guy who reads the script and
thinks okay we got to do this that'll
cost that that you know you save money
to get rid of that so you know I'm
trying to raise that for it and if
anybody wants to finance it call
Brillstein entertainment partners ask
for Mark Turbots but but so what I did
was I took a short scene from it that I
really liked and I'm gonna do a short
film a map just to direct it and I might
even do it with my cell phone camera
because those things are so amazing now
all you need is a good lighting guy and
a good you know director of photography
and a good audio guy and you don't need
the big expensive cameras and it's crazy
because that's what an upcharge on those
cameras this phone's eight hundred bucks
you know and you can get a text in the
middle of the film yeah how nice is that
what's amazing there's big cameras you
can't even text on them what do mean get
a text in the little film like if you're
shooting it on an iPhone yeah you can
get a text in the middle of the film you
can order food oh yeah as you're filming
if you want oh as you're watching a film
yeah oh oh both really I mean as you're
filming what if in the middle of a scene
it's going so great you want to hit up
post mates you don't think you just
gotta close that camera down and open up
a new app yeah you're a big multitasker
yeah I mean sometimes you know now right
now what do you what you really poor at
doing do you leave are you OCD are you
are you do you ever like leave the
burners out on the stove no
you know you know what makes me
uncomfortable sometimes I used to have
this thing where I had to feel like all
the carpet was level in my living room
before I go to sleep
why wouldn't be level maybe like
footprints I just didn't trust the
dealers I guess or the maker like I had
all I kind of make sure it was all this
is shag carpet like I didn't know this
kind of regular now but I just had like
a look and make sure there were no you
know this weird shadows that are on
carpet when it's oh you have somebody
vacuums it and it's different direction
I liked it evened out so the film though
so 3.8 million that's a real that's what
a lot producer came up with yeah yeah
yeah it's not it's I you know I enjoyed
writing it and I enjoyed well I started
out writing as a pilot mm-hmm and we had
sold it to Warner Brothers and then we
couldn't get it on the network so what'd
they give it back to me and then I
thought well I put so much work into
this you know I look back at my computer
in the history and there's like you know
like 200 rewrites on it I'm not gonna
like just let go of that and say ah well
move on yeah you know so I thought I'd
turn it into a movie a short film so I
had an ending to it made it longer and
more characters and really came out
really well I really loved it who do you
ask for funding like you go to a studio
do you feel like you I mean do you I
don't know there's like Asian
businessman
yeah the child thinking the Chinese
brother yeah you know to be honest I
mean I know a couple of billionaires but
they're more friends of mine and I don't
write ask them for money you don't want
to impede but you so this is interesting
as I struggle with this sometimes like
you know have a pilot that I'm doing a
Comedy Central and so I was gonna ask
I was asking David Spade to do a segment
on it right and but then it was like I
asked him and then I was like I don't
wanna like yeah it's like I don't want
to bug somebody that like I don't like
asking people for stuff yeah you know
even if it's like a neat opportunity you
know I like yeah I'll hint around yeah
times I'll be in direct yeah and then if
they don't if they don't respond to that
then I get passive-aggressive everything
is very indirect for me you know asking
for things like in my family growing up
nobody would ask directly what they
wanted if we're sitting down having
dinner they would say is that the salt
over there is that the salt you know
men pass this on right yeah are you
gonna finish that you know right that
kind of stuff but um you're that passive
yeah it's just hard I don't know it's
hard in Hollywood cuz yeah you don't
want to I don't know yeah I just don't
like but I don't like asking people for
stuff yeah sometimes on this hiking show
I do I'll ask somebody they want to do
and they go yeah man that'd be great
I'm a little swamped right now but you
know you know hit me back in you know
next month and I do that and they go
sure yeah and then they cancel and then
they'll they'll cancel again and then I
know that they just have problems saying
no ya don't I don't bother them anymore
why do you think we have problems doing
that like as people why do we have a
problem saying no cuz we don't want to
disappoint other people well you have
trouble with standing other people's
disappointment and you want to be liked
you know well I had a I had trouble that
went for a long time I couldn't say no
to people and then you know when you're
married that inconvenience is the person
you're married to because you're putting
the other strangers before your family
and you know you're going to out of it
wait for them and then you know people
at home aren't happy with you people
what are you doing you're driving across
town for what yeah we have a family you
know like you know a lot of times you
know people will send a script or
something and or they'll ask you to do
something and somebody came up with a
good good answer on how to kind of get
around that oh I know what it was you
know what I would love to read your
script but I wouldn't have enough time
to give it the you know the attention
that it needs
yeah so I don't want to waste your time
with that but thank you for asking me oh
that's a good way to do it yeah yeah
like I couldn't say no to you for this
podcast even though I didn't want to do
this at all that's still regretting it
but yeah that's not like Spade right
there
yeah you know have you seen he does that
little face things like he said he's so
subtle ha what is his humor David
Spade's humor what is it like it's all
kind of conversational yes kind of I'm
I'm worth nothing why would anybody want
me you know he'll say I'm embarrassed
you to see my act it's all old hacky
stuff and then I'll get up there it's
all great new stuff I've heard before
yeah you know but it's funny you know
I'm learning also from asking people to
do my hiking show like the publicist
I'll call the publicist and some people
are really nice they'll say they would
love to do it but he's busy now and you
know maybe check back somebody else will
say thank you for your offer but at this
time we will kindly pass yeah
can we pass yeah this is it uh this is
one better the other it's better to go
to direct to people like we had Howie
Mandel and the other day proven to his
publicist maybe we don't get how you
know yeah but if we just you know
because we did that um deal with it show
remember when how we did that show you
came in episode yeah and I was uh I was
a coho I was a host on there we really
yeah I look different though we're at
Canter's yeah yeah we're at Canter's
short here yeah it's right here you know
that place only got a B rating that
place is dump dinners yeah I want it
from a sea yeah oh wow were you there
when the on what the guy works in the
back showed y'all the titties they had
in that book no yeah one of the owners
son it's part of the menu I think bro it
is I think is out is wow look at you man
you're a good-looking guy there I was a
shaven but don't want me in Howie if you
can what happened they we look at you we
could say hair slicked back how he did
it how we work out I used to work out
but he you still do something cuz you're
really lean and cut I mean I don't eat a
lot you don't I don't eat breakfast
you don't breakfast is fur I mean who
you just been sleeping you don't deserve
it that you have breakfast you just have
it later
yeah I've breakfast around 2 p.m. that's
when you break the fast yeah well you
don't eat until 2 p.m.
yeah and then how but you eat late at
night yes yeah see that's that's the
thing I just shifted everything a little
bit that's right yes you go to bed I
would do a suppository at night though
to be honest with you if they had him a
night time yeah I can throw a half of a
house where he's taking your ass [ __ ]
go to bed oh shut up that way
yeah the suppository did they had those
when you were growing up they had them
when I was young posit aureus nice take
ones though that's what I'm saying huh
but you know the whole where's the
mergers guys huh the whole thing about
eating it's a very social thing when you
go out to dinner with somebody you sit
around and everybody's eating but when
you think about it it's really a
personal thing to be opening your mouth
and there's all the pink in there in
your tongue
and you're putting food and you're
chewing it everybody seeing it you know
and it's just like if people thought
about this more I think going to the
bathroom would be more of a social thing
yeah you know because I think
everybody's sitting around on toilets
and talking around a table that would be
more of a social thing you can immediate
gratification people right and you don't
see anything
ya know good job Chuck but you know food
they should have stalls for people forty
Foods in home no Avenue well back any
well I finished this burrito yeah yeah
that's interesting yeah dude like
watching somebody like watching a girl
put a couple of like you know those
small pickles in her mouth or something
or you know watching somebody eat a
piece of rare meat or somebody eating
like a egg salad sandwich falling on
their lips and on their lap and stuff
it's really gross yeah especially if you
can't watch them go to the bathroom
which is the other side of eating really
it's really just the dark side of eating
it's like you know why do you get to
watch a me I don't know I guess it's
something you're sharing a joy of
sharing um you know kind of a sensory
kind of thing with the food that tastes
oh really likes it but certainly you
know they say a lunch meeting is good
because afterwards you're you've had
food and you're in a good mood and you
know when people are hungry they're
cranky they're double they don't wanna
make a deal but after you've had a nice
meal yeah a little wine yeah sure oh um
that sounds like a good idea what so
I'll sign onto that with you yeah but
what about like getting the gathering on
the toilet yeah and after a good bowel
movement I mean wouldn't you want to
make a deal then you know I'll give
anybody 20 percent after I'd you know
really cleanse myself out you weren't
shocked are you watched Shark Tank no my
son and wife watch that a lot they do
and I kind of coming to see it a little
bit here and there and it's it's pretty
interesting talking about making deals
oh yeah those guys are real deal makers
that's why I was wondering with the
switch whatever your connection was
there yeah yeah yeah I don't have any
ideas or otherwise I'd go on really a
bit have you ever tried to a patent
something did you ever have something
you have to make really no but I would I
think maybe I would go on with my script
yeah it backing it's a great sharks I'm
willing to give you 20%
the revenue that comes from the script
for 3.8 million dollars how great would
that be
whenever you good I don't think
anybody's ever tried to sell a script
now - especially not Kevin Nealon if you
showed up you could do it yeah I'm a
half and investigate that their party
line is always you have a product not up
business so I don't know if a script its
product it is a product if it's it's a
viable it's a physical thing that I'm
holding on to ya know in the did you
ever do any movies with jean-claude Van
Damme no but we were roommates for about
six years
ya know in Sweden yeah I lived in
Stockholm in my early 20s and he was
he's a little younger than me and we
were both into martial arts you were
yeah I'm by the way back then I went by
the name Kevin Van Zeeland Oh Han Van
Damme so we would um we worked out most
of the day did you know we did martial
arts I was black belt mm-hmm
he was a white belt at the time but he
would borrow my black belt if you had to
pick a bag to go oh yeah if he had a
dance yeah and ultimately we got
separate apartments because he would
steal my cookies all the time covered
yeah I could see that and I bet you
could even hear him I mean he always get
into the full full brawls in the
apartment you know martial arts style
Wow and we would go Tommy we took flying
out the window it's breaking stuff we're
up three stories yeah yeah and what a
sloppy eater he was talking about eating
man yeah yeah well we would have pudding
butterscotch pudding oh my everyday with
bananas oh and just lore pin it up oh
did he chew with his mouth open
no he wouldn't even chew it he would
like he use a straw he would suck the
bananas through a straw oh it was he
said it was ab work for him I saw
Evander Holyfield the Chicago air
another roommate yeah and Holyfield Yeah
right out of college
Wow where'd you guys go to college at
Syracuse no we went to Syracuse
Community College oh yeah yeah but was
an Ivy League Community College oh yeah
so is one of the best community colleges
ever I went to a poison ivy league
school you
yeah like an itch and get out of there
that's pretty bad take a break we'll be
right back yeah that was pretty bad um
did you work with Chris Farley I did
yeah yeah oh wait you guys did the diet
starts tomorrow sketch I don't have
girls yeah I wasn't in the gap oh you
weren't I might have been in a small
part but I've done a lot of sketches
with him I did the Chippendale dance
right that's right yeah and I know I've
seen these I'm sorry that I don't you
think I want I barely remember them and
you know he did weekend update' stuff
together and we did I did one of my
favorite sketches I wrote was called the
bathroom attendant I wasn't bathroom
attendant a very tiny bathroom and
harvey keitel was the house and he would
come in and I had a little tuxedo on he
thought I was using the bathroom and I
think because it was just one toilet
open toilets you know no stall nothing
and he goes oh I'm sorry I said no no I
work here I work here come on in you
know we are we number one or we drop an
anchor and we hand in the newspapers and
colognes that's awesome oh there it is
yeah that's so great
I should go and watch that oh you'd love
that one for you that's one of my fits
almost like it's almost kind of like one
of the silent movie kind of things like
Buster Keaton kind of a thing but he
couldn't help laughs and he held the
newspaper over his head because he was
laughing so much and and then Farley
would come in at the end and he was a
regular you know Bob yeah good eye you
bet man we drop an anchor yes sir don't
take his coat you know what a funny uh
what a funny idea was that your idea
yeah I could see that because I'm always
kind of when I go into a bathroom and
there's a bathroom antenna in there it's
always kind of awkward oh yeah I don't
need candy yeah you know here's a dollar
just wait outside
yeah well I have an experience I was in
Seattle I was working at a parlor live a
comedy club up there I've been there
several times oh you have yeah I like
that Club
yeah it's nice to put you tonight I know
the bathroom antenna you're talking
about do you
yes he got me a nice big chocolate bar
cuz he knew I liked chocolate and I came
up there and he gave me a big Hershey's
dark chocolate bar buzz and aadmi give
somebody a toilet yeah
here's what happened to me out of this
might have been the same guy cuz I go in
there one time and there's also a
nightclub at the other side yeah yeah a
night yeah yeah so why go in there and
uh I go I just kind of skirt past the
attendant this was a big kind of I don't
if he was back my dad very darkest kind
of darker skin that's a gnome yeah it
could have been enough so yeah this big
tall kind of chubby known with like
dreadlocks right so I go into the toilet
i Scott he comes over and knocks on the
door he's like I got you fam that's what
he said right and I'm just I'm like what
like what's going on like I don't don't
worry about it man I got you you know
like now he's like the wat like watching
out there's a security guy yeah yeah
yeah yeah so then some drunk guy comes
in and like keeps banging on the stall
right the guy starts he's like hey man
that's my that's my dude in there you
know and I'm just sitting there like I
don't know I have not made eye contact
with so they get into a full-on [ __ ]
wrestling match over me sitting in the
[ __ ] the other guy was probably drunk
you just wanted to use the stall that's
it yeah but the guy but this bouncer
guys getting all you know sets down his
butterscotch and gets off you know mr.
angry pause and so next you know what
police are a security guard or something
came in and it was a big to-do and
though I had not met anyone until I came
out had a big reveal it's really weird
when you have clubs like that you have
to walk through the the general public
you know to get to the bathroom yeah and
then you're in there with other people
at the urinal some guys next to you sand
and men love your stuff yeah my stuff
you mean my yeah yeah and you don't mean
these two ounces of freaking low flow
and then there's those clubs where you
walking from the green room to the stage
and they like to have two big beefy guys
walking by it like you need the
protection yeah you know it's ridiculous
it's ridiculous but it's almost like
there's no real middle ground kind of
yeah and what about the announcers now
the people in the sound booth they think
it's like a wrestling match yeah coming
to the stage now give it up for Theo von
five pounds or they'll say what kind of
music do you want to be played on you
know and I like when they ask us
sometimes when they choose their own
it's like it really hi having mental
loud and then you come out or you're
really low-key like hey man how's it
going it just doesn't match the intro
music you know excuse me I don't mean to
do this but uh I'm trying to be rude
gentlemen a girls scene you know I'm
sorry I've been watching that surviving
r.kelly but speaking of sex if if you
like sex you're gonna love blue to calm
blue chew it's a performance enhancer
for the bedroom
would you like to last longer and go
extra rounds well I don't want to go
extra rounds but I wouldn't mind lasting
a little longer blue chew gum makes the
first chewable with same active
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis at a
lower price than those two now a lot of
y'all know I bought some of them up you
know kind of sexual dick headers off the
internet and they make my legs sweat
some of the ones I get from India well
blue Chu it's like just popping a piece
of gum you know what I'm sayin boy
chewables they work faster than pills up
to twice as fast it only takes a few
minutes you fill out the form online and
blue Chu is on its way to you know
doctor visit no awkward conversation a
no waiting in line at a pharmacy and
here's the great deal for our listeners
we want y'all to be erect and feeling
positive go to blue to calm and get your
first order free when you use promo code
Theo
th e o so get out there and get them
erections and get that taste in your
mouth of future sexual joy just pay five
dollars shipping go to be lu e CH e w
calm blue to calm and use promo code
Theo get that erection
this past weekend has also brought to
you by Skillshare men I love this
company Skillshare is an online learning
community for creators with more than
25,000 classes in design business and
more you'll discover countless ways to
fuel your curiosity creativity and
career take classes in social media
marketing mobile photography creative
writing or even illustration whether
you're looking to discover a new passion
or start a side hustle or gain
professional skills Skillshare is there
to help you keep learning and thriving
I'm going to thank everybody that has
used skills here so many of our
listeners I got it for some of my family
members for Christmas you can join the
millions of students already learning on
Skillshare today this past weekend
listeners get two months of Skillshare
for free that's right Skillshare is
offering this past weekend listeners two
months that's two months of unlimited
access to over 25,000 classes for free
to sign up go to Skillshare comm slash
Theo von th EO vo n again go to
Skillshare comm slash Theo von to start
your two months now if there's something
you need to get into a new career you
don't have to go get these big degrees
anymore you just need to have the skill
set and you can get a skill set at
Skillshare dot-com and you might just
find stuff that inspires you you know
even if you just want to learn how to do
social media better that sort of thing
you can change it you can change things
fast what is it about do you think like
ideas for humor are innate like we come
up with them or do you think they just
come from somewhere like beyond us you
know I think it's everything feel you
know it comes from everywhere you know
you're always looking as a comic you're
always looking what could be funny it's
like now a lot of people are looking
Instagram they have that Instagram
mindset yeah oh that'll be good for
Instagram I should do that on Instagram
you know everything is like a picture
picture picture well I got a picture
that guy with a shopping cart right you
know this you know I could put that I
did that that would be good on Instagram
I could do that they do a story and but
for you and for me and I getting a lot
of comics it says your your you
a built-in default system where you're
always kind of open to how something can
be funny you know and and then can you
use it in your act
ya know am i right I mean you don't you
kind of think that way I think so as
you're saying it makes a little more
sense to me I don't know sometimes I
don't know if like we get ideas of our
own or if ideas just like come in from
like a different you know like a higher
power like a you know or something and
we're just like a conduit you know we're
just like a certain commerce it's not
some glorify ourselves or anything but
just you know what makes one person want
to say funny stuff a lot and what makes
another person not want to you know I
think a lot of it is how you your point
of view on things and how you perceive
things yeah that's a good point
you know what helps me like um you know
I meditate whenever I can
yeah and when I'm like in a kind of a
deep meditation thing I've kind of going
over my material sometimes and stuff
will come in out of nowhere matter cuz
your mind is just all freed up yeah it
really is
it's a kind of a fun thing fun thing to
do but anyway that's another thing I'm
you know this year I've kind of focusing
more on writing more things when I do
stand-up I just go down to the club and
I and how to come up with something on
stage you know you know add something or
or might have something that maybe I've
thought of like just randomly that day
you know yeah but now I want to sit down
and write for like at least 20 minutes a
day you know just sit down and take like
a topic on you know whatever it is
candles candles or anything badminton
badminton yeah is that how you pronounce
it
yeah bad men saying that store yeah they
sport it's right how you game some
people don't pronounce words the way
they should
yeah like you call it badminton yes bad
and badminton yeah and you call
badminton well I'm not saying it it well
whatever it is dude it's such a shitty
game I know here's what happens for rich
people servants set it up outdoors in
the hot Sun a rich kid comes over and
says this game [ __ ] sucks
and that is bad man it's bad men well it
could be a kids game too I think it was
a kids game with a really cheap net
that's kind of sagging in the middle
yeah but they do have like really
high-end badminton with the alerts you
know the the plastic birds that lock
what's it called shuttlecock shuttlecock
oh yeah that's what the birds are called
yeah and then
in the mallets you know the rackets are
really good you know what people are
playing a lot now I think it's maybe
older people's pickleball have you heard
of pickleball it's like it's like a
spreading like a storm everywhere like
in beach clubs and country clubs and you
know it's like um it's like paddle ball
like a paddle tennis but with a wiffle
ball yeah see there it is he's got up on
the screen
and Wow and I guess it's a lot of fun I
mean it's you don't have to like run as
quick to get to the ball you see that oh
yeah it looks fun kind of lightweight
yeah Claude Claude man down when I used
to play pickleball way back when yeah I
remember we play softball in it we had
one ball and one bat and one glove
someone got a glove right yeah during PE
at school and we had a I mean this young
this teacher who was like the most
lesbian is kind of teacher you could be
you know but all she could talk about
was how she couldn't meet any men and
all of us kids were like you are you
love women no but she wouldn't tell us
what we knew you know and uh it wasn't
really I don't think it was that much
fun PE was just a town where people
would try to sneak off and smoke I felt
like yeah yeah
back in your day yeah were you and I
were you an athlete in high school I
mean I played hoops it's like yeah I
guess I was be on the team I was on the
team for a freshman year okay and then I
was on your grades dropped you had to
get off kinda
looking for chicks yeah you know like a
deterrent women
I didn't play much organized sports in
high school but in college I played
soccer did you three years in the law
I'll see you playing soccer now played
rugby three years yeah in Connecticut I
like it cuz I always wanted to play
football you know cuz we played Sandlot
football on oh yeah a neighborhood we
had the helmets and the pads and we
played the this gang from across town no
refs and it just really brutal when I
was a quarterback you know and a buddy
might comes up to me like I was just
graduating college yeah and he goes hey
keV if we go to fearful University which
is like the next town over a Jesuit
college egos they have a football team
club football if we take one night
course that makes us eligible to play on
the team I've always wanted to play on a
regular team yeah so we took a course in
criminology and we both played football
for fearful University yeah
and I was the quarterback because their
starting quarterback got hurt so I got
to be quarterback and you know this was
like my my my dream and he got to play
all the time too and he was nominated
all-american after that year I was MVP
and we traveled on the road we played at
the college's and was it awesome it was
awesome man we were playing night games
like in Pennsylvania and this old stone
stadium there's a trains going by and it
can't hear the signals you know and it's
raining and we're on the bus and and
nobody came to our games you know it
wasn't like a big team they didn't win
and won a game a long time we started
winning and I loved it man I loved it so
much and I was the kicker too
and the next year we go back to play and
I think some of the players were
disgruntled like wanting to be
quarterback so they kind of complained
that we were so they changed the rules
you had to take full 12 credits to play
so I came out to LA to do stand-up
mm-hmm and I thought you know what I'm
gonna try out for the LA Express that's
oh it was the USFL football team at the
time that's a kicker yeah you know yeah
as I had really good hang time you know
as a punter and a kicker you put it out
there yeah and I thought I'll do
stand-up and that'll be my gimmick
he's also the punter for the LA Express
you know and luckily my career took off
in comedy before they had that day off
free agent and walk-on tryouts cuz we
were gonna get I was gonna go I was at
Fairfax High everyday with six USFL
footballs practicing my kicking you're
pretty good I was at the time yeah but
like what was like what any kind of your
specialty the old nugget louver was just
that what for quarterback it was the
Blue Lake yeah but I had a really good
arm I could throw it like I think I was
throwing like 70 yards you know because
I have long arms and but I was a good
kicker and you know I liked punting and
at the corner the corner kick was a lot
of market at that yeah that's
interesting with soccer coming into
football yeah play basketball freshman
year when I realized I wasn't black I
pretty much quit that's when did you
realize that I think probably then I
don't know really the thing in your
heart you always want to be you know I
always wanted to be black or Latino or
like at night I wanted to be you know I
feel like Japanese people always slept
better so I'm you know always wanted to
kind of morph into something different
when I needed it and once I got out
there and I was like oh man
yeah yeah I'm not gonna really you know
missing I was just missing some you know
I was just yeah I was just I guess maybe
just disappointed in myself probably but
you asked me before what's kind of new
you know what I'm doing that's new and
and I just dawned on me that I'm really
getting into salsa dancing now yeah I
love salsa dancing you know I've I would
see it when I go to weddings and stuff
where I go to some event there'd only be
like a couple breaking at the salsa mmm
I thought man that looks that's really
good man that's kind of sultry and it's
good you know it's to really know what
they're doing that's a dance that
livelier it's fun and do your wife do
you do it the wife is so well what
happened was couple weeks ago went to
Cuba for our first time and we were in
Cuba for seven days which is a real
experience man it was really fun and
interesting and an eye-opener but I took
a salsa class there with my wife and my
son he's 11 and the guy we thought we Oh
huh we pull up to this um this this
restaurant and there's a gate out front
and as a security guy out there yeah an
American guy and turns out he's our
instructor he's also the security guy at
the place yeah so we go inside and I'm
dancing with my wife and he's
instructing us and then my son he's 11
he's I'm a partner all of a sudden this
girl 11 year old cutest Cuban girl comes
in like it would be like his perfect
match and was he excited immediately
well he played it down yeah but I could
tell he was excited and she danced with
him it was like a coming-of-age like you
know John used movie I thought oh my God
we're in the middle of this thing I
thought this is I've never believed in
arranged marriages before but I'm
thinking maybe this one is the time to
do it he arranged that and so they
danced forever and she couldn't speak
any English then at the end she gave us
each a big hug and a kiss and she said
thank you thank you so I went back two
days later partially two so my son kid
like maybe can I you know further you
know enjoy cuz he seemed to like her
although he wouldn't say you know but I
could tell that I mean why wouldn't he
yeah and but my wife would had enough I
had enough of a salsa dancing so I went
back and now all of a sudden I'm dancing
with the security guard and this me and
him dancing oh wow yeah and and then the
girl can't dance with my son it's like
everything man kinda he's still talking
no did they exchange exchanged
instagrams rate like that I mean that's
what these kids do you know but I got
the card for the the restaurant so next
time I go back yeah yeah while we saw
was that interesting was it the first
moment you saw like your son have like a
well you know I'm comparing myself to
him when I was at the school like I
remember when I was in third grade had a
crush on a girl but you know nothing
came of it right a couple of dates you
know yeah but and then I remember in
fifth grade I had a crush on a girl but
by the time I was 10 and 11 you know I
always had somebody in my scopes that I
liked ya know but so he is keeping his
cards real close to his chest you know
but lately though he's been talking more
about it and what the other guys are
into and you know who they like and
stuff it's not cool so he's coming
around but I think that girl right there
I mean if just to watch his eyes he's a
little embarrassed to look at her in the
eyes and his arms was really stiff on
her back you know instead of loosen and
yeah but I wonder how she felt about it
right yeah wonder is it it must be
interesting to have a son because you
get to almost live relive certain like
moments and experiences kind of through
them is that yeah does that happen
sometimes it does it does and you get
like an immediate resurgence of like oh
oh you you you relive your whole life
like Halloween you know when he's
getting ready oh man this is cool as
immigrant would do this either that or
Christmas when they coming down to the
presents you thinking I remember when I
did that was so great I want this to be
just like that for him you know right
but it's funny you know when you're
married your wife might have a different
way of celebrating Christmas then you
remember growing up and that's like
weird because for her family it was
always like you know we put the presents
out during the week you know the weeks
before we put them out some of them
aren't even wrapped yeah we just put
them out you know that this is like a
Macy's sale although the ones that
aren't wrapped they don't put out oh
really that's but like a bike or
whatever it is earth doll don't wrap
some of them you know right and I'm
thinking that's crazy that's not how
it's done you know it's Santa comes at
night mm-hmm and he leaves and then you
wake up and you come down there's all
the presence yeah that's
Santa's not milling around the
neighborhood for a couple months it's
not dropping by oh I can't allow room
for this let me put it in here you know
yeah and then decorating the tree is
another thing like we like to put tinsel
on our tree at least she had a live tree
you know it's a real and not a fake one
and we like to put a lot of tinsel on
she doesn't know no one tinsel on each
branch and you have to do it
individually it's gonna take a month to
do that yeah
so it really created like a lot of like
you know unharmonious kind of like
negotiating about Christmas it could
give to negotiate your traditions and
that are your like your memories that
you want steadfast and like their recent
like what am I said what am I thinking
you have to negotiate your what is it I
mean you have to kind of validate your
your your tradition of your life and
your family and that's the way it's
supposed to be right it's like almost
like a religion you know yeah but it has
to be different now because you have to
like yeah that would be tough for me too
having to negotiate like little moments
like that's where you probably really
learn to be like a husband or a
significant other that's where you have
to kind of give in but also the stocking
you know the Christmas stocking yeah
that goes on the bed that goes on the
bed so they wake up before us in the
morning they have that like an appetizer
you know they can take out the little
toys out of a stocking have the
tangerine at the bottom and then and
then you enjoyed that in bed because if
you leave it you know by the gifts
downstairs it's not gonna go for the
stocking until later and they won't
appreciate it as much they're gonna see
the big gifts and the you know the iPad
and whatever you know and and then
they're gonna see input that's the way
she wanted I said okay it's wrong but
okay and of course he didn't see the
stocking until the end and then he kind
of went through it yeah that's nice yeah
yeah two weeks later he finds it like a
melt bunch of melted [ __ ] down by his
feet in his yeah what is this what says
he's doing this mom needs to do the wash
that's what he's thinking the same with
the Easter Bunny she says it's an Easter
dog I said no it's a bunny it's an
Easter Bunny
she said dog getting uh but yeah we used
to do on what we do yeah I'm trying to
think it do we had a guy I was talking
about this yesterday on on Joe Rogan's
podcast that would put like around the
holidays you'd always get those little
Hershey kisses you know yeah this dude
in our neighborhood
mr. Patrick and he would put one on each
shoulder of your shoulder you know when
you get it trying to lick him off and
get him off you know what was that
holiday um I don't know if it was
holiday it was just like around when
they had Hershey Kisses for sale so I
guess I then it was like around the
holidays around Christmas or January
back when they were selling those kisses
those Hershey kisses yeah and doing get
him off is pretty fun you know the do
might have been a pervert a thing but it
was a fun you don't think how much fun
it is to try it because you couldn't
knock them off yeah yeah but when you
think about it in hindsight this man
watching three or four shirtless kids
trying to eat chocolates off their
shoulders pretty not too you know yeah
yeah I know but you know that's the
thing about traditions too with with the
holidays it's like even like
Thanksgiving yeah uh they didn't have
turkey her at her house
it was kitchen pigeon was it Bob oh
that's very well we just had I was
talking about this ility we just had two
owls at my sister's house you ate them
yeah I they serve them up I had some
yeah well one died have no these are
Al's in the tree
yeah these rules in the tree and there's
not much meat on if you want to bring up
a picture actually owls are [ __ ] full
of [ __ ]
they're very nosy whoo-hoo yeah any
business that's okay yeah yeah Mexican
lucky anis yes yes what's that one on
the left there that's a now that's after
you take its coat off really oh dude
yeah oh it's like a like an alien
oh man it's like a Japanese girl in a
Patagonia yes like squirrels are cute
but they're really rats aren't they with
furniture and we'll look at it dude
imagine they grilled up two of those man
and little kind of scary oh man but we
can you imagine having that flexibility
in your neck we can almost turn it all
the way around oh my god Oh Matt yeah
can you I mean just the I mean I'm
thinking about oral sex I don't think
about eating soup in a lot of fun ways
but a lot of stuff you could so they're
all feather mostly yeah it's all pop
yeah and they're not nice they're none
whoever did that we are made them all
fancy and they you know they're in the
library and they're working but they are
wise they wait on that limb for a long
time I think I think you know when
should I get that Mouse that's a good
point yeah it says sometimes the way for
days
watching its path watching it move very
calculating watch Harry Potter yeah so a
lot of owls in that it's so good huh mmm
a group of ours is called a parliament
and really yeah what is a group of a
geese as a gaggle gaggle gaggle
parliament that's good to know in
Parliament what about a group of um what
about a group of Latinos like that are
like robbing stores is that like a
trouble gang I think it's ms-13 I'm so
worried about being um you know
offending somebody or doing I don't like
that's you'll be fine no yeah yes I mean
that they were robbing I didn't mean
Mexicans in general you know just like
we have a lot of Mexican listeners I
love Mexican mail me to people and I
want to be Mexican next time a lot of
people will know that and then I'll
maybe be black after that I love how
much people love their country and I
think Mexicans are a lot like that they
love Mexico oh yeah their culture their
heritage I was in Cuba like I said and I
went to keep one time actually did you
yeah we went to us how long ago this was
in 2002 that was like - how long was uh
it was I was available to Americans we
do how did you go I was honest I was a
student this is a thing called semester
at sea are you Canadian nope
oh that's right you're from Louisiana
Louisiana but it's French down there
it's a possibility but no I'm polish
Nicaraguan actually but we went down
there and we had we had some wild times
went to a baseball game we had some fun
but I interrupted you I was gonna say
the Cubans are very proud of the country
but not so much their government oh the
government not as much no but they love
the country
yeah oh I remember that we would sneak I
remember at the LA moon to a library and
all the books started at like che and
Fidel there was no history before that
and we walked on the street and people
with someone I serve it to their windows
and tell us they needed help tell us
like you know I don't know what they
were talking about a lot of times it was
Spanish and they were just like say like
yeah I was like I learned a lot about
their history wasn't there I mean I knew
a lot about before I got there but you
know the 50s was all American they're
building American buildings there you're
a capital building looks just like ours
oh you helped the tunnel under the bay
there it's Olly good construction and
the cars of course you know are from the
50s and and then chair of Che Guevara
and Fidel around 59 60 they came in and
that was it
shut it over yeah yeah so a lot of their
history starts in 59 and or whatever it
is 68 Guevara it's like his big tourists
like image down there you know and all
the t-shirts his picture right but he
was from Argentina uh revolutionary and
he was going all these countries he died
in Bolivia cuz he went there and they
caught him and killed him but he
wouldn't do anything about his own
country Argentina which was interesting
interesting
but as and then I also learned that che
it was not his first name that was more
of a friendly endearing kind of a thing
like hey pal bye how buddy Jay Jay
triggers Realtors name was Ernesto got a
nest in that stall I like that name yeah
I could be I think I could be easily not
Spanish but I could definitely be
Mexican I think it seemed like so much
fun man axiom people most of the Mexican
people are they just have good family
they have good like very sweet yeah and
he at least a fight outside of the car
wash and when I was in Nice you go to
school in Tucson for a little bit
University Arizona oh nice big party
school yeah they would fight over there
by the carwash sometimes but do you
speak any languages besides English
let's be a little bit of Spanish that's
it
when you say a little bit what do you
mean like donde el baño is a where's the
menu um I could say mi padre yes de
nicaragua i could say yeah yeah
do you watch the narcos i watch the
first season I heard the third seasons
good I'm watching that now yeah dude
what about you were in weeds I just
remembered that's right I forgot about
that how great that was fun yeah eight
years eight years only how talented was
the other guy that was in it like her
nephew the guy that played the everybody
was great in that show and yeah in the
my hat the mom was that like Juanita yes
was that like just amazing to be like on
a cast where was like is it can you tell
whether the acting is really good during
a taping and when it's only yeah I mean
I learned so much in that show watching
mary-louise Parker yeah you know her
acting choices were just so of out of
nowhere and they were so great and you
know Justin Kirk played you know the
uncle the uncle he was so good yeah man
he was they were
also good she was amazing Justin's I
mean he's always working he was in that
movie Angels in America I think it's
called angels and something like that
I'm Tina but really good actor and you
know Hunter Parrish and Andy milder and
also Elizabeth Perkins what played my
you know love interest oh yeah and oh
yeah she was good she played Celia
yeah Celia she was agreeing she was good
I got to go back and watch it show again
I quit watching when they moved to
Mexico or something that thing yeah I
mean they would say eight years and uh
it's like SNL you know I saw Chevy Chase
once and a long time ago he goes you
know people don't realize this but on
SNL in the original years we had maybe
one out of every three shows was good
you know a lot of people don't remember
the bad stuff that's how we survived I
think in general as humans is we don't
remember the bad stuff yeah and
otherwise we wouldn't go on to go on in
life you know it might give up kind of
early that's a good point huh it's like
when people want to get back together
with your ex they forget the bad stuff
sure or they miss them you have to say
excuse me you remembering the good stuff
yeah try to remember the bat's why you
broke up for them to yeah that's so true
it's weird yeah I guess it must be a
survival mechanism yeah
do you feel the same way about as Chevy
does that you only had one out of three
shows were good or oh well there's
definitely some shows that are better
than others
you know in some shows are kind of you
know you wonder why they pick certain
sketches and you know yeah that stuff's
yeah can't see every you can't be like
every show can't be like perfect and
great you know some are gonna be better
than others better hosts better musical
act yeah that was the cool thing about
being on that show with the musical acts
do cuz I got to see my you know my idols
coming through their water I don't think
they're wrong with me but but you know I
James Taylor
oh yeah Simon Eric Clapton even so great
the pretty woman guy had to oversee
Overson was on here Lee yeah I mean I
could go on and on you know Dolly Parton
so and then someone that would stay
afterwards and do a concert in that
little studio
Clapton or Paul Simon James Taylor I was
a big fan of James Taylor
when he came on the show I thought oh my
god James Taylor and Steve Martin who
was also big fan of his and um and I
played a guitar my whole life I grew up
trying to figure out the way James plays
the song lifts up the needle on the
record and you know over and over and I
had gone to a lot of his concerts and
now he's on the show with me and I get
to meet him and we become friends and
we're talking he goes you know he said
to me at the end of the first shows you
know I say this a lot but I would really
like to get together with you sometime
Wow you know and have lunch or something
I said sure so he took my number I
thought he's never gonna you know or I
got his number I said the Lots is gonna
happen you know I called him oh so
nervous like going on a date yeah call
me goes yeah let's do it and I go up to
his I find this apartment in New York I
go up the elevator and it's one of those
elevators that open up right to their
apartment you know yeah and I knock on
the door and he answers the door my
heart's pounding he's got a little dog
he's holding the bong to his wife he
hears alright let's go and we go we have
Cuban we had Cuban food some Cuban
restaurant and then we go back and the
whole time I'm worried how do I say
goodbye when we get back to our kiss
what's gonna happen yeah yeah
but yeah so I became friends with him
and see these guys like I went to the
40th reunion you know yeah it was huge
yeah and I'm sitting in the front row
and Paul McCartney's getting ready to go
in with Paul Simon and I'm sitting with
my wife they're all lined up right in
front of me I'm right in the front row
and all of a sudden feel a tap on my
shoulder I look up as Paul McCartney
goes how you doing how you been good
it's good see you again you know I
forgot oh you have to try to know him
Wow Paul Simon same you know is it
interesting as you start to meet more
celebrities up it gets a little bit
easier to meet them you know yeah you
realize they're all people what they
have their insecurities you know they're
all you know whatever they are they're
humans you know like I'm starting to
realize that even in my own life just
meet it like just like people that used
to be my heroes are now not like my
peers but it's like I'm just I find
myself in a lot of the same circles as
them more often yeah it's so it's like
yeah it's like I don't know I feel like
I don't I don't know but it's
interesting but it does get easier to
meet like I remember I went to Adam
Sandler's Christmas party years ago when
they had the bowling alley Christmas
party
yeah and I had I'd smoked if this one
weed pans had just come out people
smoking the pan and I didn't know I
thought it was a cigarette so I'm
outside so does a pen I thought it was a
pen yeah right they're [ __ ] yeah I'm
out there on some you know hopped up on
some decent ink so but yeah yes I hope
this out there and I thought I was a
cigarette so I walk in the party and
that's when I start meeting everybody
from Adam Sandler movies like almost in
a row my friend was introducing me to
them it was only Benjamin actually he
introduced me to all these Adam Sandler
stars and the weed started to hit me and
I didn't know I was high and so I
thought I couldn't handle meeting
celebrities like I [ __ ] came down
with like an illness when I met them and
it got worse and worse and I believe I
did it huh you thought your hair like an
anxiety it so when I met Don Cheadle at
that point I was like I couldn't yeah I
thought something was wrong with you and
I went home yeah yeah you know
and I was like [ __ ] dude I am Who am I
gonna ever work with because I'll be in
a wheelchair I mean if I mean Michael
Landon I'm gonna go no damned coma
[Laughter]
so that was a yeah I mean you just you
know but but now it's like a little bit
easier like I guess you also see people
around and then you get to just there
were two people typically I'm really
comfortable around anybody hmm and I
don't mind going up and saying hi cuz I
think maybe it'll recognize me you know
although I did see Bill Clinton I
finally met Bill Clinton two summers ago
in Lake Tahoe at a golf thing and he
came out and did a little speech to the
players you know and and he stuck around
afterwards he's meeting everybody and I
went up to him and I said hi mr.
president I'm Kevin Nealon and I'm
waiting to see his recognition but it
looked like he didn't know who I was oh
it's good because I made a lot of fun
with him on SNL yeah
but two people that I did not approach I
was in a restaurant on the west side it
was pretty empty the restaurant I was in
the back room there's maybe eight tables
back there and I'm sitting with a buddy
and these three people come in yes it in
the corner table by the window and I
eventually see my friend recognizes them
and I turn and as Julia Roberts and
Julie Andrews Oh
and they were having a happy
conversation and then there was a the
husband or something with yeah some guy
I thought oh my god those that's some
talent over there and Julie Andrews from
The Sound of Music and you know Mary
Poppins oh yeah I really would like to
say hi to them but I'm afraid and I
didn't go over and I left I was so
nervous but I met Julie Ann I met Julie
Roberts before she was like a star oh
really came to SNL when you're because
she was a huge fan of James Taylor's so
she came to the show before she was
which is a stunning then yeah she was
just young and kind of loud I remember
her being loud I see that like
Christopher Walken she was loud yeah and
she was I remember she had a loud laugh
cuz she was behind me in line at the
restaurant afterwards for food she was
cackling you know how she does and and
then she became Julia Roberts
but I was afraid to go over there and
say anything cuz they they were they
were like they're strong women you know
yeah her and she might say excuse me
we're having a conversation right cuz I
saw Paul McCartney do that once I want
to see love the grand opening of love in
Vegas mm-hmm and they had a VIP party
afterward love is a musical it's the
it's a Beatles kind of a thing itself
it's circus Olay with the Beatles music
you know and they're it's really great
yeah I saw it and I saw I go to the
party and Paul McCartney's there at the
party afterwards and he's talking to
some guy and oh my god some guy came up
to him a fan with a couple of albums and
he interrupted Paul to ask him if he
would sign the albums and I remember
watching it Paul turned to me and he was
he was in such disdain he turned to me
goes I'm having a bloody conversation
here no I'm not gonna sign your albums
I'm having a conversation
yeah can't you see him having a
conversation with somebody so rude I
felt so embarrassed for the guy too but
he was right I mean it was rude yeah but
yet here's your idol you know is he's
still a fan of Paul McCartney's it's
true huh I bet he probably is I bet you
don't want to meet so no you don't want
to meet your failure he's telling
everybody Paul McCartney
you know nobody follow me out yeah told
me to [ __ ] off well yeah that's true
about you don't want to meet your idols
I remember I went to the AFI was
honoring Steve Martin that's American
Film Institute yeah and Sarah Silverman
got up and he's talking about Steven I'm
just talking about in general about
sometimes you don't want to meet your
idol because you
disappointed yeah you know and she goes
the only advice I have for you is don't
meet Steve Martin it was so funny it was
so funny that's funny but I was not
disappointed James Taylor yeah you know
he's a nice guy that's cool man even
just have a moment like that oh yeah
yeah yeah I have a buddy um a friend of
mine his name James Blake he's like a
musician and and my friends at home are
like in nay and I didn't know anything
about it he got hurt it before but I
didn't know I'm not a music guy really
you know and what kind of guy are you
I think I'm not you know I just like to
listen to the thoughts in my head just
spin around you know until I just really
go and go any hobbies
I don't know this really I guess but
before this what did you have I like I
like to go to the gym and you're your
gym rat I was for a while you read like
the real day we should do steroids man
did you really yeah no way
oh dude you blew over dude I was
freaking ye no I wasn't like that but I
was definitely any long-lasting effect
on you you know I think sometimes my
back is a little hairier than usual and
I think I maybe had some erectile
dysfunction for maybe about a decade but
outside of that I don't think so my my
brother's tears older than me and he
looks a little younger than me I think
so I think it kind of runs you a little
forwards yeah yeah he didn't take him he
didn't so I'm sure you're talking about
Jim Blake James Blake yeah yeah but yeah
it's just funny like house to some
people somebody's such a you know like a
it's it sweet it depends on how you're
introduced to a celebrity as well you
don't know if you don't know of them and
you meet them it's almost so much better
because then and then you find out that
they're like such a celebrity then
you're like oh you had a different
experience with them yeah the worst is
when people don't recognize you yeah you
know I get repeat I have a face all the
time people know me they recognize me
within us sure where they know me from
and it's like a guessing game from a
loser you look like one of the ball
players from who you you're like a
sports announcer right or you play
baseball or golfer or
are you uh you golfer you brought you
shop at Ralph's right dizzy gillespie
aren't you Hewitt you am I you work at
my bank don't ya know I finally I'm
going then if I say you know me because
I'm your gynecologist yeah on your
hiking show or some of your favorite
ones um oh there have all been great for
me they're all different you know I've
had everybody it's not just comedians I
have like just notable people I had
Diana Nyad and swam from Cuba to Key
West
oh we had a girl who's just about this
sail the Atlantic
she's a boat captain oh nice she's gonna
row the Atlantic solo so that's that's
okay she had so I've had Bobby Kennedy
jr. on oh yeah I know him Brad Paisley
oh yes I saw you last night with it with
the laughs act that's right yeah yeah we
were tall so he's a funny guy yeah he is
really funny good songwriter and I've
had lots of comedians and actors on you
know I Caitlyn Jenner I hacked with
Caitlyn Jenner that's awesome Jack Black
Sandler Conan O'Brien Jimmy Kimmel and
these are all on You Tube yeah on
YouTube that's youtube-dot-com
forward-slash Kevin Nealon comedy or you
know hashtag hiking with Kevin uh yeah I
started I started posting them on
Instagram I just do a little short
two-minute things like three parters or
a minute on Instagram and then Howard
Stern was a fan of it he goes you should
make these longer I thought yeah I
should but Instagram doesn't saw
Australia YouTube channel so that's what
I did so I made him like you know like
they for like 17 or 18 minutes now
that's awesome yeah I mean and that's
from like an hour hike so I really edit
it down and and everybody's been great
you know some people don't like to hike
incline so much they like spate will do
flat oh yes I don't know Speight said
yeah I hate with Kate Beckinsale a
couple weeks ago I hiked back to my
apartment alright so I'm sorry
around the old bit we have a question
that came in here for you from a
listener related related to the hiking
show okay hey hey
this question is for Kevin Nealon I live
in Los Angeles and a avid hiker and I'm
curious what your favorite hike was hope
to hear from you
gang gang Chiyo young man and that guys
I was thinking us hide on the trail and
kill you but where are you gonna be
Kevin
you know my favorite hike favorite trail
I mean just a trail alone without the
conversation there's a couple of great
hikes I liked the one of Soulstice
Canyon in Malibu which was beautiful but
it's all scorched now because of the
fires
oh really yeah that's gone but the fires
that bad oh man have you driven through
Malibu huh
it's like it looks like the moon once
you get past Pepperdine up in the
mountains and I mean as far as you could
see black Wow and then it jumped over
PCH too so this homes like a Point Dume
that are burned down there's only
standing it's really bad and it goes we
could drive all the way up PCH it's
almost done Oxnard and it's all scorched
do you think some people deserved it do
you think yes but they don't live here
but yeah so that was that was like my
favorite hiking place solstice Canyon
but I I've had great hikes with
everybody's been so great and
interesting and different you know you
really can't I hate doing that thing
where you know what was the best oh yeah
yeah it's like Rolling Stone will come
out and say who the best you know like
SNL character of all time they'll still
read it you know and I hate cars things
yeah you know and then or you know I
don't know just I I don't like that
whole kind of comparing and or who's the
best comedian because it's so subjective
oh they have variety comes out with a
list every year of like top or one of
these magazines have you polled
everybody in the world right and half of
them are just like industry people
they're trying to force-feed and yeah
nobody whatever even finds funny that we
couldn't even stand on a stage yeah a
lot of times people say who's that your
favorite host you work with an S or no
and you know you have hosts that you
work with that you enjoy doing cuz
you're fans of them but everybody was
great everybody's so scared on that show
they become your friends forever yeah a
lot they glom onto you like you know
help me get through this and then
forget it every time I run into a host
that was on he like and I was down there
20 30 years ago they remember me it's
like my body's a man died in vain it's
like we've been through a battle
together that's cool yeah do you it
sounds like you've had some good
experience in your life where you've
kind of gone from group to group like
with the sports and then with the with
SNL and then even the eight years with
with weeds do you like where you kind of
got to be in groups like worth the
camaraderie and stuff like that that's
pretty that's pretty lucky cuz a lot of
people don't get that in their lives as
we get older it's like most of us get it
when we're young if I'm a team and then
I know that you're just in the world
that's why I encourage my son to get on
a team because you know it's so
important know about teamwork yeah and
and how much more you get done with a
team instead of doing everything
yourself
and as stand-ups you know we're
stand-ups so that's really it doesn't
get any more individual than that or you
know I mean it's all you writing it
you're performing it and it's harder
it's hard to like have success that when
it's just you and it's lonelier I guess
a little bit is it lonelier or is it I
don't know if it's lonely but at least
you you're doing it your way right and I
could tell you probably the best time
I've ever had it the most fun for me was
as a stand-up during The Tonight Show
Johnny Carson and nothing has ever
topped that for me SNL or weeds nothing
I'm just it was just a thrill of a
lifetime because Johnny Carson it was it
wasn't really the only game back then do
you do The Tonight Show with Johnny
Carson that's what I heard oh and then
you know I can't was behind the curtain
and they introduced me Johnny introduced
me in the curtains open up and I'm
thinking I'm doing it I'm doing it you
know yeah and but and applauding I'm
walking out and I forgot my act no I
forgot my I couldn't remember I'm
standing on the mark the audience
finally dies out and thank God I
remember my act and I did it and I got
laughs and then applaud breaks and
laughs I heard Johnny laughing over my
shoulder and I'm thinking I'm an avid
man I'm doing it up on the night show
because I knew my acts so well cuz I'd
done it so many times right and then I
finished he calls me over for the panel
I sit down with him and that was like
icing on the cake
and uh and I've never had such a natural
high between doing that show and before
it aired because I knew that was and at
the time was it mom yeah and at the time
you know when you were a comic like The
Improv was mostly where I worked I knew
every comic was at The Improv watching
it on that TV over the bar you know huh
you're like I'm gonna be a star in seven
I'm telling you man
wow man you know was it I can't even
imagine and it looked like things were
so much more pure than in a way well
I've heard you say that you kept the oh
yeah I have the answering machine tapes
from all of my buddies that called and
and say hey great job you know people
like Brad yeah Paul Reiser you know
agents and stuff Paul Reiser office on a
flight Riesling he has two is a couple
sons okay and they were one of his sons
turned around they were sitting in front
of me as I came in I'm such a big fan
it's cool I didn't know that Paul was
there otherwise I would you've got a lot
of fans out there in fact a buddy of
mine uh his son is a big fan like Jake
wolf they live in Florida oh that's cool
yeah so Jake what's Jake like Jake is
cool is he yeah he's really cool what's
his son like that's sweet of you man I
appreciate that
that's nice I'm not such a fan but he is
like you're like yeah it's weird it's
interesting having fans isn't it well
you can't really you know you're
grateful for them but they're so um mmm
ethereal you know it's not gonna you
can't expect them to be a fan for a long
time because somebody else will come
along and oh wow you know it's like
having a girlfriend yeah so yeah I guess
you just feel grateful for the time that
you have where there's like you fool
interest yeah you fooled them yeah
they're your fan for now laughter they
find out the truth it's like being
fooled and like until they come back and
see you again you're doing the exact
same oh that's why don't worry about
that when you get on stage and yes same
person like from the first show there oh
it's the first well the first thing I
ask people is even last night I was
leaving the store and summary story yeah
the comedy story uh and no Vons actually
all people that are out here though
what's your leg
you'll say you know I got the light and
people think what do you mean get the
light yeah he was smoking yeah and he I
was leaving the comedy store and they
had yes some guys the first thing is I
came in we love and I was like oh we've
been here twice they said I was like oh
did you see I didn't do the same stuff
that I that was like but it's always
like my concern
I don't yeah there's some want people to
be unhappy I guess I did a spot at the
store Ralph I did store the store a
couple acts last year and there was this
these two girls are on the first show
and they had a great time you know it's
front row laughing and I came back to do
another show in the main room again and
they were in there and not one smile
they look so disappointed yeah and I was
trying to make them happy and not the
rest of the room you know so I was doing
a little bit of different material yeah
just to please them Wow show that I
wasn't a fraud yeah
otherwise I would have killed in that
room you know did um was your mom is
your mom alive
yeah is she pretty proudly so much you
really pray yeah yeah yeah yeah and my
father was too he just passed away about
eight months ago he's 92 Wow he lived a
long life yeah he did he did yeah they
were both very proud of me but they
weren't liking I was very lucky I have
the parents that I wish everybody had
you know really but it would be like
evenly killed in life and not have
problems because they were just perfect
you know they're just everything that
you would expect in a parent and um it
wasn't like they encouraged me to get in
the stand up but they didn't protest it
and they were you were funny yeah yeah
but in hindsight I heard my father was a
little nervous you know that I was
getting to stand up with a degree in
marketing right and but they were always
supportive yeah and very encouraging you
know as I was doing it but I'm sure that
they were nervous and did you make your
parents laugh a lot when you were young
like you remember any yeah yeah we all
laugh oh you do there's five kids of my
family oh that's and I was three for a
long time and then 12 years later there
was two more you know but we were going
road trips and we lived in Europe for a
while my father worked for German
helicopter company for about four years
back then and we would travel all around
Europe and you know we would take
vacations to Greece I learned how to
swim in Greece I learned how to ski in
Austria you know that's great
like you said I learned how to ski in
pudding after that we're not a swim in
Greece but if you like you to learn how
to swim
actual grease but we would be like in
the car a lot and so we're always doing
games and trying to one-up everybody you
know and I would get a lot of laughs and
I could still picture my father laughing
and my mother laughing and it's fun yeah
you know it's funny you know what's
interesting is like yeah it's like even
like you're saying like the good
memories are the ones that stay with us
are the good things that happen to the
good parts of the episodes
it's like yeah even having your parent
when you remember one of your parents
laughs yeah is um my father would laugh
like this I do it yeah breathe in like
ah I would hear I'm like in my bedroom
they're having a party and a couple
people over some cocktails he always in
it like this is that right there's
always that is that right is that right
that's cool but I do love laughs you
know when you listen to people in the
audience if you could just single out
everybody's laugh it's such a personal
like it's us nobody has the same laugh
snowflake I have a friend actually who
has the most distracting high-pitched
laugh we know his name is Gianni he's
our intern and we had a no not that guy
okay this is somebody that he's a loud
laugher and it's really high-pitched and
it sounds like a crazy King oh you know
like if you saw Mozart that movie a long
time ago they played that he had that
high-pitched laugh anyway he's such a
fan and he'll sit in the front row and
he will laugh like that and it's totally
distracting to the audience but what do
you tell him don't don't laugh hey you
know ya mono your joy buck oh yeah it's
funny it's just like it having the organ
it's like an orgasm probably in a way
you know oh it's like it's like sound
it's like sound coming out of your face
it's just like it's totally uncontrolled
no kind of parameters just this is I'm
omitting my emotion of love and joy and
surprise that's it right there
I have joy in me yeah and crying is the
same way the other end inspect these one
time I got laughed so hard one of my
shows came out of the closet bro
unbelievably we're just like told his
body he was yeah and they're like damn
brand another beer dude beer go see and
go home with your wife and his buddy
tighten up man do we have some other
calls that came in yeah we got a couple
we had a couple fans accenting some
calls Kevin Kevin Nealon the Matthews is
in from Portland Oregon I've lost my
voice but I have to know what was it
like filming Grandma's Boy been working
with the great Nick Swardson Gang Gang
Nick Swardson yeah yeah he's so funny
man he's so funny
he's a wild funny he's just he's a he's
always thinking about stuff and you know
he's too funny when I read that script
Grandma's Boy I was doing a lot of
Sandler movies you know what Sandler in
them and then this one came to me from
Allen covert and Nick Swardson and I
read I thought this is this is where I
got to draw the line man it's just too
juvenile you know it's just too
sophomoric you know I mean I thought it
really was kind of unsettling I thought
this is kind of embarrassing to be in
this film you know it's funny but you
know I want to try to take a little
higher road you know
yeah I've been standing at ChromeOS
Neill and I really hope you do this film
because if you don't do it and it's a
big kid I'll feel bad but if you you do
it and it's not good nobody'll see it
anyway I said okay I'll do it
it was fun and so many people love
Grandma's Boy you know I didn't do well
in the theaters I don't think but it
became like a cult classic on you know
on video and yeah it's like the John
Wilkes Booth thing yeah so that was uh
that was a fun movie and I loved my
character in it - it turns yeah turned
out really well he's so funny in it even
I remember like I saw him it just for
laughs in Toronto or something and we
were just hanging out during the day and
he even watching him he was talking
about how he went trap easing on some
film or so yeah and he just he put his
arms up in the air and I just died
laughing he just
says there's so many natural little
things about him that are just are so
like I don't know what it is
he's like a funny person there's a lot
of comics that get laughs yeah but
they're not necessarily funny people
yeah they're delivering jokes that are
well-written right and you know they're
pleasant to watch but some people are
just funny yeah honey he's an
experienced Bobby Lee is like that I
feel like to a lot of times yeah I mean
he's very physical you get guys like you
know spayed is like that he's funny you
know he's a funny character kind of guy
yeah Swartz in and you know I mean I
look at a list and tell you Jerry klauer
do you ever meet a comedian Bryan
Regan's funny guy you ever media
committee know Jerry clower no he was
like my favorite comedian we put the
trim name oh really
yeah he's from yes I don't know him from
Yazoo City Mississippi is one of the
best all time selling comedians he
toured a lot um that was him that's him
yeah he's got as he still alive no he
passed away let his out he is a cousin
saw me he had a whole career sold out
places and I don't think I know the guy
and I used to know all these comedians
he died in when he it would have been
too old for you he was way too old he
was born in is a Civil War comedian I
see but he uh he has some of the best
words in his album some of his albums
you get the best of the best of Jerry
Clower oh it's great he's like Andy
Griffith he's like a storyteller right
yeah he's extra yeah yeah and then sort
of guys are like that yeah it is a
wonder why that is are all storytellers
we got more time yeah people have more
time to tell us were over in New York
you got to tell the Biba to get to the
punchline Jack you know your next
special should be shot Louisiana where
you're just on a road a porch
you had to buy you just rockin and
saying and it's one time yeah you know
my mother said to me we'll see Oh rabies
breath yeah you know Bruce got it
brother who's done hey don't come in a
cup and tell me it's milk that's what my
neighbor he say all the time
and I don't know who that guy was I got
was yeah
who knows what happened any other ones I
hear we go over more hey guys
longtime listener first-time caller this
question is for Kevin Nealon what is
your favorite dumb comedy okay good
question actually your favorite dump
caught me like film yeah what is it what
do you watch Kevin Oh like what film was
dumb yeah dumb comedy something dumb or
one of one that you enjoy well any
Sandler film yeah does it make you laugh
more because you know him personally
like it's not that he they're not dumb
movies they're actually really well
crafted and they're interesting and
funny but a lot of the characters
sometimes are dumb in them you know yeah
but I like um I think my favorite comedy
film of all time is the Heartbreak Kid
with Charles Grodin you ever see them
are you gonna watch that and let me know
what you think of it after you say it
don't watch the remake watch the
original one with Charles Grodin the
Heartbreak Kid Heartbreak Kid yeah but
dumb comedies you know like you know
Animal House I guess was dumb and Auggie
Shaq how many more we good Tommy Boy
yeah dumb another film Dumb and Dumber
yeah that's so good huh that was a dumb
movie did you have the opportunity to
work with Jim Carrey or no I don't think
we ever worked together in a film or TV
show I wasn't hosting SNL when he came
on did you guys pass each other in the
comedy halls sometimes oh yeah I would
see him at the comedy store early improv
yeah we worked on the same rooms you
know it stand up but not on a show a
movie you're in he had a level of Fame
that was probably similar to Farley's in
the sense that it was like a be aa
like almost bigger than existence it
seemed like or something yeah I mean he
was an impressionist you know he would
do these very obscure impressions and he
in a rubbery face you know yeah but
Farley I always wondered what what he
would be doing now if he was still alive
you know would he I mean you can't carry
that energy forever I would see him in
the halls at SNL you know and he'd be
just wired and I say I see Chris man
what's going on he goes oh
you know he'd be sweating and stuff I
say you got to take it down a notch you
know I see that a lot to him anyway and
he'd always anticipated and he'd be
doing somebody see me well take down
notch I see think I'm not I go yeah you
take it down a notch man as well we just
come from a party and stuff I said you
know I said man that's just slowing you
down man you he was what Belushi used to
you know do la drugs and poverty and
stuff I said yeah but just think about
how much better you be without doing
that stuff yeah let me be able to have a
clear at the head and think really
really yeah do you think he tried to be
like Belushi said oh yeah totally wanted
to emulate him and be like him Wow I
even till the way he dressed you know
the shoes yeah I think I remember seeing
Belushi a few days before he died I was
bartending at the improv you speak
bartender there for two years
yeah I remember and this was like 1980
hearing about that and Belushi came in I
don't know if I was bartending that
night maybe I was just there but it was
empty was dead it was like these rainy
nights yeah and there and Belushi came
in around 11:00 o'clock
looked around looked in my so high he
said hi and he left and then a couple
days later his dead but Farley was yeah
big fan of his he said you know I mean
he died the same age 33 Wow
SNL you know and he know you couldn't
cannot you couldn't you could there was
no stopping it
no yeah no but it's interesting
sometimes people will guy though very
lovable oh yeah so yeah I've heard a lot
of nice things about him I mean a lot of
people have come through here have had
stories about him yeah and his brother
actually texted me the other day or sent
me a DM and said oh I saw the picture of
my brother in your studio it's really
sweet oh this is a great painting what'd
you get it there's a comedian named
Brady Matthew started doing these and
this is the original now there's a lot
of replicas around town but I bought his
first one and this was it I spent like
all the shellac on it yeah some people
think it's Masonville think it's some
guys had here the whole time I thought
it was Trump he's like yeah Chris Farley
yeah but yeah just I don't know man I
guess like and you know like a lot of
like you know he probably needed some
help at some core levels that he wasn't
getting in total his head you know so I
think yeah a lot of our audience relates
to that kind of stuff I just did it
approve
in love yeah a lot of comics they're
just looking for some kind of you know
approval yeah some type of acceptance do
you feel that because you seem to be
kind of you seem to be a little bit more
even-keeled than a lot of the guys maybe
at one time I needed that but now I'm
dead inside
you know I'm pretty much dead I have no
they'll get nervous nothing happens
anymore
I think I was probably I probably
growing up I felt inferior yeah actually
I didn't feel like I was adequate you
know intelligent wise you know I felt
like I was and even though I wasn't dumb
yeah just very average kind of you know
student and and I just felt maybe like
comedy was something I did well you know
I got laughs people it made people happy
so you know I love doing that and the
three guys that really influenced me the
most before Drake before getting into
comedy I grew up watching Jerry Lewis
films and watching all the old-time
comics on talk shows and stuff I would
always watch the talk shows and see the
comics but Steve Martin number Brooks in
any Kauffman Wow
those were the guys and I'm friends with
two of them now and any Kauffman I met
at The Improv and talked to him I would
see him all the time I watched him
perform and I remember asking him
outside once you know he's outside by
the door and I knew he was into TM yeah
and I said tell me about TM what's that
all about you know I'm so nervous and he
talked like a half-hour and I was just
staring at him I was I wasn't really
hearing I was just look at his face the
balls on his face and stuff I thought
wow I had a conversation any Kauffman
you know that's cool yeah yeah that's
cool man yeah I could imagine that's and
it's funny because the lower goes on
it's like those guys you names are all
like I mean those are guys that I would
never even have the abyss those are like
Mount Rushmore faces almost you know
yeah and the cool thing too is both
Steve and Albert I mean like I said I
became friends with them and they're
both fans of mine working out oh that's
fun which is great I mean nothing makes
me happier than that yeah when you have
a peer that you really respect and then
they really have made a mark in your
life when they come back around and say
oh man what you just did or that was
great that was great
you know it's really it's really
remarkable and fun do you you know I was
performing one night in Damon Wayans was
in the back of the room and I grew up
with watching in living color that's
really when I first got like watched
comedy yeah and I heard him laugh one
time like in the back of the room and
hit like he was like in one moment my
whole world just was complete for a
second it was like sure
here was somebody that I'd left so many
times - growing up we would impersonate
him in the street you know all like
these defunct characters in his psyche I
was laughs and he had to go whatever I
heard it was just like man it just made
me feel so good you know yeah yeah or
one time I went on stage yet before Bill
burr it was at the levity live downtown
in Los Angeles a man I crossed I really
had a good set you know sometimes you
just like [ __ ] I didn't think that was
gonna I didn't think it was gonna happen
and I'm walking off and we locked eyes
and he was just like wow I was a good
set man you know just like that's crazy
yeah yeah I know I did the horn once it
was a comedy club in Santa Monica a long
time ago this is like the one of the
last supper clubs
mhm and they'd have a singer and then
they'd have a comic a singer in a comic
you know a new one huh yeah so I do my
act I do my little set and this is like
I'm pretty new at it you know it's a
couple maybe three or four years in hmm
and I come off and I'm going by the bar
and start by the bar and there's this
guy like a che in the shadow and he's
got a Mets baseball cap on the old-time
Mets baseball cap he turns to me and I
see it's George Carlin and he goes hey
man
stick with it it's good Wow and you know
I remember that yeah I wasn't me doc
Gooden first of all it was James Blake
of all people wow that's crazy huh yeah
yeah and but there most all we need
though that one little thing to keep you
going but also from somebody that you
respect or something yeah when somebody
that you really respect you're like [ __ ]
they see something in me like is that
and when it's somebody you don't respect
and they like you know of course you
like me I'm good
yeah what do you expect um Kevin Nealon
are you torn right now I got a lot of uh
tour dates coming up this year yeah okay
a little Canadian tour in April - oh um
but I have a website Kevin Nealon calm
and all my tour dates are on there okay
and we'll say I'm at the beginning of
the show - whenever we do a little intro
thanks so much for coming by
thanks for having me man this is really
this is a nice place to be in a rainy
day it's really cozy it's kind of like
you know a room in your house or
something yeah we've been trying to Nick
makes it Nick's made it more cozy Oh
over the years even and we shoot the
other episode face in that way so that's
our Sunday night FSA's face is that what
he knows yeah but yeah it's been a real
blessing man it's just like doing the
podcasting has been fun no it's good
it's good that's that's the cool thing
now that you know everybody has access
to you know it's just some kind of
platform to show their comedy yeah you
can't complain say man I don't get any
air - only at stage time yeah you know
get a youtube channel going yeah donnell
rawlings was here he said no more
excuses anymore he's right you really
can't have an excuse no matters you know
of any gender a Dre all this he's like
you really can make your own thing ya
know it does take a beat of like bravery
or maybe somebody to tell you hey man
stick with it or good job right but well
thanks for having me buddy yep thanks
for being here
[Music]
it's gonna take
a little time for me to set that parking
brake
Oh
[Music]